bonjour donc on va faire une petite
inspection
alors qu'est-ce que vous êtes en train
de faire ici
pour aller m'expliquer ce que vous êtes
en train de
on fait pas comme ça ils ont enlevé tout
de suite tout et vous décongelez dans le
frigo ça c'est pas bon d'accord allez-y
tout de suite Gilles est inspecteur des
services vétérinaires on décongèle pas
comme ça l'eau chaude parce qu'on
maîtrise pas la température ou à l'eau
froide qu'on vous allez les remettre
là-bas il contrôle l'hygiène des
restaurants de la Côte d'Azur
allez
ça s'est mis en fonction ça va être
utilisé après comme vous êtes en train
de faire la mise en place enlever votre
montre
tout ça là
ça c'est sale c'est pas nettoyé
régulièrement donc ça ça risque il y a
un risque de contamination pour les
dangers vous allez manipuler voilà c'est
tout c'est pas plus compliqué que ça
bon alors
ça c'est fait pour être
là d'accord c'est pas fait pour être
l'été pendant que les vacanciers
profitent de la plage des hommes et des
femmes de l'ombre veille ils sont
inspecteurs la direction départementale
de la protection des populations
restaurant supermarché mais aussi
camping ou club de vacances rien
n'échappe à leur contrôle
[Musique]
sur les bords de la Sorgue dans le
Vaucluse les adeptes du canoë-kayak ne
le savent pas
mais ils sont sous la protection de
Marie Carmen
donc en fait ils sont numérotés
on regarde un petit peu on espère
spécialisé dans le contrôle des
installations sportives et hôtelière en
fait il faut que toujours l'endroit où
l'enfant va s'asseoir et tous soit
toujours très lisse il y a pas de risque
ou de coupure ou des chars de tout ça
j'aimerais s'il vous plaît que vous
montrez ce que vous avez un stock en
termes de loup d'accord de dorades et de
l'autre en Camargue
Ivan lui est spécialiste des produits de
la mer très consommés en été ils sont
une des principales sources d'infections
alimentaires origines Chine du grossiste
aux restaurateur il passe toute la
filière au peigne fin
[Musique]
dans le Var Lucien et Marie Dominique
eux travaillent en famille
et leur spécialité ce sont les marchés
provençaux qui parfois peuvent être des
pièges à touristes
à l'huile d'olive
donc c'est
sortis d'un homme des fois quelques
grosses affaires démarres comme ça avec
quand on a des petits indices collés de
police c'est pareil vous n'avez pas de
facture encore tous traction relâchent
les fraudes et les contrefaçons pour
garantir la sécurité des consommateurs
ils devront se montrer particulièrement
vigilants le temps d'un été à la DDPP
[Musique]
au gros du roi dans le Gard
Ivan et Jean-Pierre ressemblent à des
touristes comme les autres pourtant ils
sont en mission
je peux passer à côté de gens qui vont
faire digestion en vacances il passe des
vacances bien mérité pour eux j'imagine
tu vois ça nous fait ni chaud ni croix
voilà par contre après quand on est en
vacances
et voilà
on arrive dans le centre ville de dans
le cœur du village du Grau-du-Roi qui
est très mignon c'est sûr et là c'est
c'est commerce tout azimut là commerce
tout azimut c'est le
terrain de chasse de la ville et
commercial le connaissent aussi je suis
pas sérieux
il le gars il doit être soulagé il se
dit ah il prend pas la direction de ma
boutique donc ouf
Ivan et Jean-Pierre sont en quête d'une
spécialité locale un coquillage très
apprécié des touristes la telline
bon voilà là comme comme le pressentait
mon collègue Jean-Pierre il y a
effectivement des tellines pour faire la
vente et là les tellines du premier coup
d'oeil tu t'aperçois
voilà
est-ce que tu peux t'occuper des gens
toutes les factures sont là si il le
faut il y a la maison
ils font voilà ils veulent voir pour les
produits
[Musique]
alors le problème des tellines c'est des
tellines locales
il y en a qu'une à retenir pour les
tellines c'est 2,5,5 cm mais là moi je
regarde le fait pas 2,5
de la des deux extrémités là on est à
deux hein
et qu'est-ce qui vous disent qu'est-ce
qui vous disait
merci
à grave aussi ça s'appelait le fardage
ça à l'époque c'était vrai pour les
fruits et légumes on mettait les beaux
fruits en dessous du cajou et voilà mais
même des cailloux des fois à la place
mais là
l'homme peut y passer la journée
quand on parle avec des gens qui pêchent
les tellines ils sont quand même très
souvent dans le déni
ouais ils doivent considérer que la
réglementation n'est pas faite que cette
métier dur ça doit ouvrir que c'est un
métier durant ça c'est pas le sauf que
c'est pas le sujet taxi c'est un métier
très dur c'est pas pour autant qu'il
faut pas respecter le code de la route
je pense je sais pas je suis pas
gendarme mais moi je suis pas payé au PV
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que les
filles qui soit sur le marché le soir
conforme c'est tout
c'est là aussi
voilà c'est un réel problème
pendant qu'ils vont vérifier les
tellines Jean-Pierre lui a repéré
quelques indices lui laissant craindre
un manque d'hygiène
il procède donc à des prélèvements
on fait la recherche
bactériologique sur sur ces produits là
de façon à apprécier à la fois la
caractère de dangerosité du produit
éventuellement il y en a et l'état
sanitaire en lui-même
ça me dégrade un peu dans mon travail
parce que voilà moi je sais que je
travaille
correctement
ne pas le plus correctement du monde
parce que d'une année à l'autre on en
rajoute toujours au niveau de l'hygiène
ça devient bientôt plus possible de
travailler pour les résultats du
laboratoire il faudra attendre plusieurs
jours faites attention à vouloir déjà
trop trop attiré le challenge des fois
on se trompe ou on le trompait donc
pour les tellines en revanche le patron
doit s'acquitter d'une amende de 1500
euros
et c'est clairement quelque chose de pas
bien je l'assume on le laisse comme ça
je vais pas faire jeter ça dans les
poubelles
ça me fait mal au cœur regarde ça elles
peuvent être consommées mais mais c'est
pas bien j'espère que la sanction de
financière permettra de dissuader ce
genre de choses
il faut que vous nettoyez donc du coup
effectivement bon courage merci la loi
impose de détruire toute denrées jugé
dangereuse les tellines sont trop
petites mais ils vend les estimes
consommables
près de Nice dans la petite station
balnéaire du Cannet
Gilles va faire une découverte beaucoup
moins agréable
il arrive par surprise dans ce
restaurant
le responsable ce monsieur bonjour
Monsieur Francis de la DDPP sécurité
sanitaire des aliments je vais faire une
inspection dans votre établissement
les gens rentrent pas dans une cuisine
n'importe comment
[Musique]
allez c'est parti monsieur vous êtes en
train de travailler en cuisine à partir
du moment où vous êtes en train de
travailler en cuisine on doit être en
tenue de travail une tenue de travail
conforme il doit comporter au moins
comme votre comme mon employé comme
votre employé chaussures pantalon
vareuse
ça marche pas comme ça
lui en tenue vous l'êtes pas ça c'est
pas bon
l'été la chaleur pose de gros problèmes
sanitaires surtout dans les frigos
quelle est la température c'est entre
trois quatre ça dépend oui mais là il
est là mais à l'intérieur ça doit
tourner entre 0 et 4
règles en discuter après mais là vous
avez m'écouter d'accord les températures
qui doivent régner ici doivent être
maximum 4 degrés Celsius on est déjà sur
l'afficheur digital à 5 mais est-ce que
c'est vraiment le cas mettez votre
thermomètre docteur et après on verra ah
oui là en effet il y a plus trop de
poignées
vous allez voir des surprises
si je vous dis ça c'est pas pour
5,7 degrés Celsius donc tout le stock
est là le stock il y a de la mise en
place là après je vais vous montrer j'ai
une chambre froide
là vous allez tirer les cheveux mais
j'en ai plus
ajoutez les oreilles alors ça c'est la
partie sous-sol on a arrangé comme on a
pu c'est pas trop mal
on vient de faire de la purée donc on
l'a mis aphrodir vous allez me dire
normalement il faut une cellule de
refroidissement aussi je sais pas que je
vais vous le dire c'est sûr
qu'on fasse ensemble tous les
établissements
vous avez pas de cellules donc vous vous
arrêtez de faire ça
on ferme l'établissement
pas de souci on va remonter ça n'a rien
à faire là
non mais la cellule je sais qu'il faut
que j'achète bah alors alors
vous attendez quoi
pourquoi
ça vient d'où c'est moi qui l'ai surgelé
comment quand
il y a quoi
je vous montrer la facture après je
dirais j'ai défait tout de suite et je
l'ai sauvé
[Applaudissements]
aucune preuve comment aucune preuve
aussi je vous montrerai il a pas de
souci la viande a pu être congelé
plusieurs fois ce qui est très dangereux
allez montrez-moi les factures voilà
c'est quoi c'est une facture c'est un
bon livraison
et voilà la facture bon il a dû me
l'envoyer avant donc la marchandise elle
est arrivée est là le 3 0 6
on sait pas s'il a eu une transformation
c'est à dire une congélation une
surgélation quelque chose comme ça il y
a pas d'information on sait pas quand on
sait pas qui c'est pas comment je vais
mettre je vais mettre un avertissement
ça veut dire que la prochaine fois il y
aura une contravention et Gilles et du
genre incorruptible
moi non ça va merci
aucune souplesse les viandes sans
étiquette sont détruites
vous savez c'est vous qui prenez la
météo
vous allez en mettre plein votre truc là
la prochaine fois ben écoutez vous
commandez vous gardez les étiquettes
la première fois il faut toujours une
première fois oui je sais d'accord et
j'espère que ce sera la dernière
merci beaucoup merci
pour l'instant la prochaine fois mais
faites le nécessaire pas de souci
dans la profession Gilles s'est taillé
la réputation d'un inspecteur
intransigeant et il l'assume en trois
mois lui et ses collègues des
Alpes-Maritimes ont fait procéder à 14
fermetures de restaurants
demain il ira voir le dernier d'entre
eux pour envisager une réouverture
mais une surprise l'attend
sur le littoral les dangers et les
arnaques ne sont pas que dans les
restaurants
près de Toulon en Provence Lucien et
Marie Dominique se sont levés tôt ce
matin pour faire le marché
de randonnée des fois le week-end
Lucien et Marie Dominique vivent tes
travaillent ensemble
ces deux inspecteurs de la DDPP tracent
les étiquettes des produits régionaux
vendus au tourisme
arnica
et les crampes
à une minute vous avez pu le prendre ils
se font d'abord passer pour des
touristes
[Musique]
et des escarres de l'hypertension de la
bronchite de la migraine
vous avez compris
musculaire les cervicales et dorsales et
lombaires les coudes les genoux le talon
d'Achille ça va tout simplement des
nouvelles et c'est tous les cris en
provençal non
en français donc il faut économie une
contre étiquette quelque part dessus
dessous qui donne un minimum
d'informations non pas toi mais en
français
ça laisse parler
mais mettez une contre étiquette avec la
traduction sur ce marché provençal il y
a un produit qui surveille
particulièrement car il fait l'objet de
nombreuses fraudes c'est l'olive
les condiments en fait des produits
dérivés de l'olive
avec juste l'indication d'un lot donc
[Musique]
le responsable de ce stand nous indique
qu'il achète les peaux comme ça sans
étiquette juste avec un numéro de lot là
il y a un risque de botulisme
donc nous la constatation de produits
comme ça non étiquetés on vient vous
croire vous les revenus recevez comme ça
en revanche
là
du produit alors que ça n'est pas vous
qui avez fabriqué au départ vous avez
les documents de vous a parlé du risque
botulisme alors c'est pas comme on voit
le mal partout c'est pas ça mais vous
avez entendu parler Avignon il y a
quelques années il y a eu un cas de
botulisme grave avec de la tapenade et
le gros culisme enfin je sais pas si
vous savez ce que c'est mais ça peut ça
peut entraîner la mort il y a des il y a
des dégâts énormes derrière dans
certains cas mais là là il faut être il
faut être vigilant là-dessus c'est la
raison pour laquelle on vous l'indique
on insiste sur ce type de produits
l'étiquetage n'est pas conforme aux
normes spécifiques à l'huile d'olive on
n'a pas l'origine de l'huile d'olive
même si l'indique huile d'olive de velo
vélo
Rhône les huiles et les olives ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que la France produit
uniquement 10% de ce que l'on consomme
autant les olives que les huiles grosso
modo c'est ça ce qui veut dire que dans
n'importe quel circuit de distribution
neuf fois sur 10 c'est pas un produit
français les olives en général c'est
Maroc Espagne encore une fois c'est pas
un problème de qualité on dit pas que
les olives du Maroc sont pas bonnes ou
les olives d'Espagne sont pas bon c'est
pas ça le problème c'est que il faut pas
non plus laisser croire aux clients que
on a des olives françaises des olives de
la région
[Musique]
des bouchons du Rhône on a certainement
impérativement
tomber la pression
c'est peut-être mieux
mais on ne vous oblige pas bonne journée
allez bonne journée aventure
de retirer le produit parce que
manifestement il y a pas de d'éléments
en plein sanitaire et de danger
particulier mais vu la multitude
d'anomalies sur les ticotage et les
tickets qui est pas bien collé on peut
penser que c'est relativement artisanal
et qui dit artisanal des fois on tombe
sur des petits faiseurs qui font des
coups comme ça et de l'huile qui est
prétendue française
on se retrouve avec de l'huile espagnole
au milieu du Maroc ou jeux de jeunesse
ce jour-là le vendeur a accepté
l'intervention des inspecteurs
mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas
dans quelques jours vu sien et Marie
Dominique vont devoir agir sous
protection policière
dans le Vaucluse la Sorgue fait le
bonheur des vacanciers
malgré son apparence paisible cette
rivière est parfois dangereuse
Monique et Marie Carmen sont
inspectrices de la répression des
fraudes
aujourd'hui elle contrôle ce camping
situé sur les rives de la sorte
du camping tous les campings sont
équipés du même message pour une
évacuation des
tests
cette alarme sert à prévenir les
touristes en cas d'inondation
il faut voir bon là vous voyez ça là
voilà là voilà parce que de partout
regardez ça accroche
il faut absolument éviter qu'il y ait
des risques avec des écharpes et tout ça
un peu la maintenance quotidienne là il
faudrait passer et balayer un petit coup
un petit peu les graviers parce que là
c'est juste bon pour que pour qu'un
gamin mette le pied sur gravier et
tomber ok en fait c'est à nous de
d'anticiper et d'enlever tout ce qui
peut créer un risque pour eux voilà
parce que les gamins vous voyez il joue
donc voilà
voilà
Marie Carmen et Monique ne sont pas
seulement là pour sanctionner
mais aussi pour aider les professionnels
du tourisme à satisfaire leurs clients
la problématique c'est que si les
établissements sont mal entretenus et
tout ça va être forcément des plaintes
ça va bon alors à l'heure actuelle en
plus avec internet c'est catastrophique
parce que de toute façon ça ce véhicule
a une vitesse et donc ça va être au
détriment quand même du département
c'est une grosse partie de l'économie
nous le tourisme donc on a intérêt à ce
que les gens repartent content voilà
mais depuis quelques années de plus en
plus de particuliers ouvre des maisons
d'hôtes
un nouveau terrain de chasse pour ses
inspectrices
anis au siège de la direction
départementale de la protection des
populations
Gilles débute sa journée
lui ne manque pas de terrain de chasse
5 6 7 et 8 à faire
ok c'est quel genre de plainte alors ici
on a une pseudo toxine infection
alimentaire donc on voit la traiter en
plainte c'est sur une un camion pizza
des plinthes adressées par des
consommateurs
supermarché la viande est verdâtres
passer de couleur je le fais surtout car
beaucoup de personnes âgées se servent
dans ce magasin et risque une
intoxication alimentaire
et ici
nous sommes regrets de porter votre
connaissance des éléments difficilement
acceptable en matière d'hygiène
catastrophique de A à Z que ce soit de
l'état des chaises aux toilettes en
passant par les cuisines le personnel
etc etc rien n'y coupent ce restaurant
Gilles le connaît bien
donc on va faire le restaurant et on
verra bien ce qu'on trouve
il a ordonné la fermeture de ses
cuisines la semaine dernière
si tu es dans le Vieux-Nice il
présentait des risques sanitaires élevés
Gily retourne pour décider s'il peut
rouvrir l'établissement
bonjour
c'est quoi
si ça sert à rien il faut l'éliminer
sinon il faut le nettoyer
bonjour monsieur
c'est vous qui avez fait le nettoyage
bon on va recommencer parce que il va
falloir tout nettoyer correctement
je vous explique
regardez là
tout ça ça va être nettoyé
[Musique]
par contre quand je vais revenir là on a
un problème de joint quand même regardez
ça ferme pas bien donc forcément
regarder ça marche pas bien
nettoyage vous reprenez le nettoyage
encore ça bouge encore là
je sais c'est trop tôt
c'est encore vivant
le problème de Carrefour
jamais jamais ils sont tous morts
vous avez le siphon qui a encore bouché
là
on va aller voir juste en bas pour voir
pour vérifier
la fuite a été réparée non
quand est-ce qu'elle sera réparé la
fuite
à la fuite
[Applaudissements]
allez
encore un traitement entre deux jours de
plus bon alors le problème c'est que
les insectes sont en train de mourir
mais ils sont encore là
regardez donc c'est pas encore nettoyer
moi je peux pas laisser l'établissement
ouvert si on a encore une infestation et
il faut absolument il faut absolument
que les frigos sont en fonction d'accord
allez je vous laisse parce que de toute
façon vous avez du boulot
pour les gérants cette fermeture d'une
semaine ce sont des milliers d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en moins
pour éviter ce genre de désagrément
mieux vaut se conformer aux demandes des
inspecteurs c'est en tout cas le choix
qu'a fait le restaurant du Cannet
averti par Gilles la semaine dernière
[Musique]
alors ça c'est un calamar minute avec
des frites maison
le persil on y va s'il vous plaît la
salle alors un calamar
depuis l'inspection quelque chose a
changé dans son établissement
[Musique]
alors ça c'est quoi ça voilà donc par
rapport à cette visite de l'inspecteur
sur l'hygiène enfin les conformités etc
donc on a fait l'achat de cette cellule
de refroidissement et voilà ça refroidit
les éléments
ça coûte cher le passage à l'inspecteur
quand même bah écoutez n'importe comment
c'était un achat prévu mais oui enfin un
outil comme ça coûte à peu près 3 3000
euros mais bon enfin voilà c'est quand
même une nécessité maintenant dans dans
notre métier d'avoir des outils
performants adaptés aux nouvelles règles
d'hygiène etc donc il va dessus il y a
pas de souci voilà c'était c'est un
outil vraiment indispensable
cet investissement pour lui c'est le
prix de la tranquillité
au gros du roi pendant leur pause
déjeuner Jean-Pierre et Yvan préfère
oublier pendant une heure qu'ils sont
inspecteurs à la répression des fraudes
mais ce n'est pas toujours évident
[Musique]
moi non alors vrai même pas alors
Jean-Pierre je sais pas donc j'essaie de
faire attention effectivement au choix
du restaurant mais malheureusement on ne
peut pas toujours tomber comme il faut
et
voilà et après les suites on les connaît
une heure après en général sinon vous
vous rendez compte la vie
chaque fois on devenait complètement
phobique de tout en allant on sait de
toute façon que fatalement tous et on
est similaire et demi sur la planète on
est en ingurgite tous les jours des
choses qui sont sûrement pas très bonnes
pour nous écouter après j'ai demandé
quand même s'il y a pas des
à 10 km de là la ville médiévale
d'Aigues-Mortes et ses nombreux
restaurants touristiques
Ivan part à la pêche au fraude
[Musique]
et de dorade voilà bourride de l'autre
13,80 € bon c'est peut-être de la lotte
franchement de la lotte la vraie bon
c'est quand même difficile de les
retrouver après le menu à 19,80 € dans
une place aussi touristique que ça on
est là aussi voilà un menu à 12,90 €
filet de loup normalement ces poissons
coûtent très cher Monsieur
pour avancer voilà il y a un de vos
employés et après quand vous avez fini
vous nous rejoignez Yvan est intrigué
par ces prix très attractifs j'aimerais
s'il vous plaît que vous me montrez ce
que vous avez un stock en termes de loup
de dorade et de l'autre
et voilà
pas tout à fait
c'est l'autre de Chine origine Chine
sur la carte et comme sur le menu du
jour il y a marqué bruit de l'hôtel
Boris de lotte c'est réglementairement
prévu pour la lotte le poisson lot la
lotte d'ici là c'est là c'est la route
de chinois
il faut que vous le sachiez en tout cas
son prix d'achat aussi
ce qu'il faut que vous reteniez c'est
que la lotte tout court et la lotte de
Chine c'est pas le même poisson donc sur
votre carte il faut indiquer l’autre de
Chine alors ça peut paraître pas des
plus porteurs c'est possible mais
pourtant c'est ce qu'il faut faire
[Musique]
on va aller chercher c'est loin
Yvan a des soupçons sur d'autres
poissons inscrits à la carte on va
simplement le poser là pour l'instant
vous allez être démoralisé mais la Dora
de ses basses c'est différent de la
droite la dorade sébastes vont corriger
c'est une dénomination commerciale tout
à fait légale ça aidera de Sébastien et
l'adora de tout court malheureusement
c'est pas le même poisson que la droite
c'est basse donc tout ça entretien une
confusion
et des méprises parfois
non mais ça c'est possible que ce soit
super beau mais c'est pas le même
poisson allez on vous laisse passer
devant parce que c'est chargé c'est pas
lourd
le restaurateur s'acquittera d'une
amende de 1500 euros pour dénominations
mensongères et il devra changer sa carte
c'est dommage c'est c'est de la petite
tornade à la petite semaine mais c'est
de l'arnaque généralisée alors bon
et il existe un autre poisson dont
l'origine est souvent usurpée l'un des
plus chers le loup aussi appelé bar à ne
pas confondre avec le loup de mer voilà
comme c'est beau
[Musique]
intuitivement on voit bien que le bar
d'abord qui est très rarement présenté
un filet qui achète un bar au restaurant
c'est le bar en entier tu vas chez le
poissonnier tu l'achètes il est en
entier c'est un beau poisson un bon
poisson etc le loup de mer c'est c'est
une tête c'est dégueulasse quoi tu ne
verras jamais un loup de mer tout seul
on va essayer de lui trouver s'il te
plaît une la tête d'un loup de mer là un
arrêt casse lupus et hideux tu tu mets
ça sur les tailles de Me poissonnier et
tout le monde s'en va
c'est assez loin du bar quoi mais là
depuis le temps que ça existe cette
fraude là ça existe avant même que le
lot existe quoi
les gros poissons Lucien et Marie
Dominique les trouvent parfois sur les
marchés nocturnes ou je sais pas ce soir
ils sont à Fréjus et pour l'occasion ils
sont accompagnés par des policiers en
civils
[Musique]
les grands
la direction départementale de la
protection des populations
vous faites le marché tous les jours
aussi tous l'été
pour la vente de ces produits ou pas
c'est un problème de contrefaçon de
marque
ça c'est quoi la vie est belle c'est
celui-là
à la limite ce qu'on vous conseillez
c'est d'enlever surtout les étiquettes
oui
des références à des marques
relativement connues il y a une
correspondance très très direct mais par
exemple ici Nina Ricci numéro 5 sans
commentaire avec un essai une victime
des c'est Dior pour homme dès que
l'infraction est constatée la police
intervient à son tour
je vous en prendrai son procès-verbal
la suite
le procureur décidera des suites à
donner sur la procédure
cette opération conjointe avec la police
permet d'accélérer les enquêtes en
saisissant le parquet plus rapidement et
les procédures elle permet aussi de
protéger les agents de la DDPP devant
cet autre stand les policiers restent à
distance et dissuadent le commerçant
d'un éventuel débordement
alors là warning machin made in China il
y a rien en français
ce produit là vous l'avez comme ça comme
l'achetez vous avez la facture là du
fournisseur non bon des ballons il y en
a 9 10 11 12 13
ballons si on est appelé à relever nos
contraventions c'est par nombre
d'articles que la contraventions est
relevée donc 13 ballons 13 contre
aventures parce que c'est pas normal de
trouver des
moi je sais pas comment ça marche pour
une simple amende le montant peut
s'élever à 1500 euros pour ces 13
ballons malédictés le fournisseur risque
un PV de 10000 euros des sommes qui
suscitent parfois des réactions
agressives de la part de certains
commerçants si jamais ça peut
il y a beaucoup de monde quand même donc
je pense pas qu'un commerçant s'amuse
à être grossier ou violent
mais néanmoins
on peut constater qu'il y a moi géré une
dégradation un petit peu de la relation
humaine et qui existe entre contrôleur
contrôlé
pour X raisons c'est la société qui
évolue certainement aussi j'apprécie en
tout cas
ça c'est de la nacre c'est de la nacre
du plastique
à Avignon au siège de la ddp Marie
Carmen elle travaille plus sereinement
elle s'intéresse de près au tarif d'une
maison d'hôtes
je pense que la plus chère c'est la
première parce qu'il nous donne le prix
là
au lieu de 230
[Musique]
au départ quand les gens ouvrent les
chambres d'hôtes
leur conception était que c'était pas un
hôtel donc ils avaient l'impression que
ils étaient pas soumis au même règle que
l'hôtel donc on essaie de rééquilibrer
un petit peu surtout que là on arrive
bon dès qu'on arrive sur des chambres
d'hôtes introductions on arrive sur des
prix qui dépassent
le prix de la majorité des hôtels
la maison d'hôtes est située dans le
Parc Naturel du Luberon dans un luxueux
domaine d'un hectare
dans le Luberon Marie Carmen agent de la
DDPP contrôle cette luxueuse maison
d'hôtes
c'est l'avantage de des contrôles il y a
des fois on voit de très jolis trucs
ah non mais c'est
donc celle là c'est laquelle voilà c'est
la chambre essentielle d'accord alors
une petite chose qui vous a un petit peu
interpellé donc on a vu vos prix
affichés à l'extérieur et sur le site et
après on se rend compte que quand on va
par exemple sur réservé les prix sont un
peu plus beau
ça c'est les prix qu'on a quand on fait
les tarifs après quand on déroule vous
savez les chambres on a ces prix là donc
je vous le dis quand ça c'est les prix
basse saison ça c'est
le site internet le module de
réservation prend les prix les plus bas
et ensuite quand vous notez les dates il
vous donne le prix de la nuit actualisé
d'accord oui parce qu'on comprenait pas
certains prix affichés sont ceux de la
basse saison il ne correspond pas
toujours à ce que paie réellement les
clients
la gérante devra mettre à jour son site
internet et changer aussi le nom d'une
de ses prestations
comme le parking
et le hammam donc la séance est payante
elle est à 30 euros les massages les
massages idem ça fait partie ils sont
fait par une prestataire donc qui est en
freelance sa profession elle est quoi
elle est diplômée elle est je dois avoir
son diplôme elle est kinée
donc si elle est pas une professionnelle
de la santé il va falloir enlever le mot
massage c'est les diplômes que m'a donné
que me laver la praticienne en arrivant
c'est tout en anglais je sais pas où
c'est que c'est fait c'est des instituts
c'est des certificats mais ça pas une
je pense que ça n'a aucune valeur voilà
elle va être contente de l'apprendre
alors ça aucune valeur quand on prenne
bien sûr pour pouvoir employer le mot
massage parce qu'en fait les clients
étrangers ils connaissent pas le mot de
l'âge mais là il va falloir lui marquer
nos massages sont des modelages
corporels non thérapeutiques non
médicalisés il faudra quand même nous
enlever le mot massage donc voilà donc
là on fera on vous enverra un petit
courrier pour bien vous rappeler la
réglementation allez on va à la piscine
c'est Jacques le mari de la propriétaire
qui l'emmène ensuite vérifier la piscine
donc en matière d'affichage alors vous
avez les affichage qui sont ici
pour ce qui concerne le bassin
laquelle profondeur votre piscine
un mètre 90 j'avais un mètre 90 ici
alors
mon petit souci c'est que c'est pas très
visible
donc ce qui serait peut-être bien pour
la saison prochaine c'est plutôt que de
le mettre sur le bord
c'est de le mettre comme ça là
parce que la notion est donnée que ça
doit être visible du bassin
vous voyez quand la personne est dans
l'eau c'est pas visible voilà alors une
évidence quand même puisque vous avez un
bassin qui est en pente douce et je
pense que le chèque
[Musique]
et on va donc grosso modo vous voilà il
me manque juste à améliorer on va dire
ce marquage donc
quelque chose de joli oui les normes
quand même c'est un petit peu pesant non
effectivement
on peut trouver parfois un règlement un
peu tatillon mais s'il a été édicté
c'est qu'il sert à quelque chose même si
en tant que Français on n'aime pas trop
ça c'est sûr
en 22 ans de service Marie Carmen a
procédé à des milliers d'inspection à un
an de la retraite elle a le sentiment du
devoir accompli
moi par exemple par rapport au moment où
j'ai commencé
l'amélioration on l'a vu donc ça prouve
que quand même on sert à quelque chose
voilà donc cette notion d'utilité voilà
de pouvoir rendre rendre service puis la
notion de service public qui quand même
important je pense qu'on y est quand
même attaché
à Nîmes
Ivan et Jean-Pierre viennent de recevoir
des résultats d'analyse
des échantillons de poissons et de
fruits de mer prélevés chez le traiteur
du Grau-du-Roi
mauvais résultat
[Musique]
en fait
donc
c'est un bien grand mot mais bon c'est
des produits ce sont des germes qui
globalement sont détruit par la chaleur
mais si sa cuisson n'est pas parfaite il
va en rester et c'est ce qu'on a c'est
ce qu'on a pu par exemple c'est ce qu'on
a pu déterminer enfin c'est ce que
laboratoire a pu déterminer quand il
nous a fait le résultat des analyses ça
veut dire que ils savent pas beaucoup
les mains alors après
c'est possible
sur 7 qui pose ce problème là sur 7 il y
a les supions Scipion grillés non ils
ont qu'on est farci c'est bon le filet
de rouget aussi le temps la provençale
la sèche aussi c'est chez toi ce qui
pose problème pareil
échantillons sur 7 sont contaminés par
des bactéries le commerçant risque
environ 3000 euros d'amende
en fait de revoir ces procédés de mes
au-delà de la sanction Yvan espère que
leur travail permettra aux
professionnels d'améliorer ces pratiques
ce que ça nous inspire c'est qu'il faut
surtout pas baisser la garde il faut pas
baisser la garde parce que ils vont pas
redresser là-bas tout seul ça
l'expérience le montre et quand il y a
des problèmes d'hygiène on s'aperçoit
aussi que les autres aspects de la
réglementation la loyauté l'information
du consommateur on fait essayer de pas
le prendre quand même bon un peu trop
pour voilà me donner ben on s'aperçoit
que c'est aussi ça suit pas c'est c'est
tout à volo quoi donc il faut vraiment
vraiment avoir un oeil sur ses
professionnelles dès qu'on les a
identifié parce que on sait que ça peut
vraiment aller vers du n'importe quoi
donc renforcer la vigilance
l'été s'achève mais pas leur mission ils
vont le sait améliorer la qualité des
produits vendus dans son secteur est un
travail de longue haleine là on est
comme un des sportifs on laisse tomber
une saison on pense déjà à se préparer
pour la saison prochaine
mais en cette fin de mois d'août la
saison n'est pas terminée pour tout le
monde
un péage d'autoroute près de Brignoles
dans le Var
Lucien y accompagne Charlotte et Sabrina
de stagiaires
c'est leur tout premier contrôle
celui-là
transporte
sur le parking
un peu le
dispositif
[Musique]
S
un produit a été décongelé le camionneur
est en infraction
mais il va tenter de profiter du manque
d'expérience de Charlotte
c'est pas la même chose et votre nom
s'il vous plaît
et votre nom
[Musique]
merci bonne route au revoir
le fait d'exiger l'identité avec la
personne refuse finalement
on a le droit d'exiger
il y a vraiment un risque physique avec
avec des contrôlés des
exceptionnellement
nous on doit rester à notre place
on doit faire en sorte de pouvoir faire
notre travail calmement sereinement en
restant poli des fois c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile
je tire ma révérence
j'ai défendu je pense j'ai essayé de le
servir du mieux possible mais bon ce
passage au relais moi je le trouve
sympathique dans la mesure on a aussi
des gens réceptifs
qui mordent
les problèmes de Toulon donc ça c'était
intéressant et c'est un peu le
compagnonnage
pour Lucien ce métier est aussi une
passion qui déborde parfois sur sa vie
privée
[Musique]
sur un plan de travail bon
tout votre corps de boeuf et puis
quelques crimées ici un peu de basilic
du pesto
oh la vache
ça c'est parfait
si il continue les marchés depuis tant
d'années c'est aussi parce que Lucien
est un bon vivant
il y a un côté un peu bonbons anglais un
goût des bons produits qu'il a aussi
transmis à ses enfants
[Musique]
quand ils passent la porte d'un
restaurant
pas du vinaigre ça servait un regard par
rapport à l'hygiène et par rapport à
l'alimentation par rapport aux
normes et enfin vraiment l'hygiène quoi
ça permet parce qu'on va au restaurant
en fait de se dire qu'il y a quand même
des personnes qui contrôlent ça évite de
manger un petit peu n'importe quoi
j'apprends et puis c'est vrai que des
fois
avec mes amis au restaurant je me dis ah
bah tiens là ils ont pas bien fait telle
chose ou
on apprend aussi c'est important pour
vous d'avoir inculqué ça à vos enfants
je pense que ça a dû prendre quand même
un petit peu parce que quand je suis
invité chez eux
on mange pas mal
donc ça me fait plaisir
comme les policiers les agents de la
DDPP sont parfois sous pression
lorsqu'il multiplient les contrôles dans
leur métier savoir décompresser est
essentiel
Lucien et Marie Dominique le font en
famille Gilles lui le fait sur son
bateau avec ses amis on va essayer de
mettre ce qui se passe une compétition
de ah ouais une compétition de de view
hacker de vieux de vieux Waker c'est à
dire que ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas fait et on est
impatient de se mettre à l'eau et d'y
rester d'ailleurs
il est bon
en plus
allez les moussaillons vous mettez vous
relevez les les gouttes
c'est chouette de bosser ici non
c'est chouette de bosser partout c'est
chouette de bosser d'ailleurs mais mais
ici c'est vrai que on a la possibilité
après de se détendre avec des passions
différentes
d'autres régions non on serait on se
concerne le ski hein
je vais essayer de pas te blesser fais
gaffe ils ont plus les mêmes réflexes
à peu près où on peut aller manger quoi
c'est ce qui est pas mal
[Rires]
et d'autres d'autres qualités il en a
pas
il faut être clair
[Rires]
[Musique]
et pour une fois
ce jour-là
que je te fais même pas t'en profite
aller
loin des contrôles ça permet d'oublier
c'est un poids à chaque inspection
on fait on fait plein d'autres choses
mais on parle pas beaucoup
parler de boulot ils m'ont rien ils
n'ont rien demandé c'est bon
ça y est allez
[Musique]
quelques heures de répit pour finir un
été mouvementé en trois mois Gilles
Lucien Ivan et Marie Carmen auront
réalisé à EU4 près de 300 contrôles et
distribués près de 100.000 euros
d'amende une vigilance de tous les
instants au service de nos vacances le
temps d'un été à la DDPP
[Musique]